Your Herald summons you another world awaits
Let it be done quickly
What happy here happy Hogan here, I know what do you want over it? Mr. Starks going through his belongings
Apparently it was a surfboard that you left behind
People over there said they think that Nick here was a surfer guys sake appearance is gonna be juicy. Not mine
Don't ever call this number again
Welcome back everyone is Charlie we have news about the Marvel Silver Surfer movie that they're working on
Obviously we have that Easter Egg during spider-man far from home. So we'll break it all down
We're doing the giveaway for spider-man far from home on blu-ray
All you have to do to enter that is be a subscriber and leave your best Silver Surfer theory on the video
The reason why they included that in spider-man far from home is the same reason why they included that
Fantastic Four Easter Egg at the end on the billboards side
and then the one in Nick Fury's sword Space Station in the post-credits scene because when they were making
Spider-man far from home the Disney Fox Steel had not cleared yet. So they could have been sued out of existence
So that's why you don't see
Fantastic Four characters walking around in spider-man far from home or the Silver Surfer show up at the end of Avengers endgame
They just didn't get the rights to the character fast enough to do the CG
That would have been required for something like that recently
We all saw Kevin Feige announced the Fantastic Four movie reboot plants during the Marvel phase for Comic Con panel right now
The rumor is is that movie could happen as soon as 2022 in there's news of a Silver Surfer movie after that
we've been hearing rumors about a Silver Surfer movie all
Year long people even thought that he might show up at the end of Avengers end game for a little while
I've already done a couple videos on the Fantastic Four teasers that we've gotten so far
So this video is just gonna be about the Silver Surfer movie earlier this year director Adam
McKay said that he intended to meet with Kevin Feige to talk about doing an actual Silver Surfer movie at the same event
Kevin Feige also talked about Silver Surfer and future stuff that was coming
We're I not on this carpet talking you right now
I'd be in the cutting room and on the mixed age where the rest of the team is
Right the second you spoke recently about obviously the coming merger, and it's a little premature to get too deep into things
I don't know if you heard I spoke to McKay the other day Adam McKay said Silver Surfer movie
I might you know, I might need to give Feige a call. Have you gotten the call?
I've not gotten a call yet
But I've seen Adam tonight and at a number of these awards and he is not only as everybody knows incredibly smart guy
He's a honest-to-goodness fan
yeah, and and you know, he did a lot of sort of behind the scenes help with us on the first ant-man film and
Have you seen Vice
Cameo little actus cameo in there
We helped him get so I look forward to speaking with him or if there is there a Fox property you're you're just excited to
Potentially get your hands on a particular that the truth is I'm excited for all of them
I'm excited and it's not just the marquee names, you know, there are hundreds of names on those on those documents on those agreements and
the fact that Marvel is
As close as we may ever get now to having access to all of the characters
Is something I've been dreaming about for my almost 20 years
At Marvel and it's very exciting Mikey. He said he just sung your praises a moment ago
He sounds like he really wants to make this work. I assume there's been no movement
You haven't called him since our talk about Silver Surfer
Some discussion about Silver Surfer my agents certainly woke up they were excited
we're in the middle of you know backing vice right now, but who knows in a couple months, it could pop up I
Really am excited by that idea
Most of you are probably familiar with Adam McKay from all of his work with Will Ferrell and all the movies and
Saturday Night Live stuff that they did together
But for the past several years
Marvel has been using him as a script doctor on their movies going all the way back to the first ant-man movie
They bring him in to punch up scripts when they're shooting movies
He's an amazing writer and he's actually a pretty good director in his own right too
And he's a lifelong Silver Surfer Stan a Silver Surfer movie would be the perfect opportunity for him to do his first big
MCU movie himself instead of just being a lowly uncredited script doctor side note
He's also behind the succession TV show that's on HBO right now starring Brian
Who was himself a big x-men character for a long time?
But right now aside from the Silver Surfer Fantastic Four Easter eggs in the Marvel phase three movies
Marvel has not backed itself into a corner with an Odin's vault Infinity Gauntlet
situation that they'll be forced to pay off so they can bring an
Actual Silver Surfer any way that they want with any kind of story?
typically that's been through Fantastic Four stories because silver surfers first appearance in the comics was during a
Fantastic Four storyline called wait for it the Galactus trilogy
Stan Lee tells this great story about how they wanted to do Galactus
so they had the idea for that character first inside the
Fantastic Four comics the way Stan Lee tells it Jack Kirby showed up one day with a bunch of artwork in this weird
dude, walking around with a silver surfboard
So Jack Kirby explained the concept to him saying that well if Galactus is this huge character?
Literally huge then he would probably have minions going around the universe helping him. So that's where the Silver Surfer came from
He was on the Fantastic Four team for a little while
But then they turned the character into this observer of humanity and used him to comment on the human condition
this is a clip of Stan Lee talking about the
Philosophy of the Silver Surfer character and it gives you a good template for how the character is going to be used when he's working
with all the Avengers characters in Marvel phase 5 and Beyond he would drain all the
Energy out of a planet to keep himself alive
he was huge and he had this huge spaceship and he didn't want to harm anybody, but he had to live and
Instead of just a guy flying around fighting for finding planets. I made him a
philosophical observer of the world and the universe and I had him talking semi
Shakespearean and biblical language and
He became my mouthpiece for how I feel about a lot of things
I told Jack I want to use this character a lot and he came to earth and
He would say things like
And I don't remember the exact words. I'll just paraphrase it, but he would talk about the fact that
We live in the greatest planet we could ever want it has everything it has
clean fresh air in a sunlight moonlight
It has all the water we could need most of the planet is water
It has beautiful growing things all the food. We could one room for everybody
Why do we fight each other? Why do we hate each other? Why? Is there chrome? What's the matter with us? Are we insane?
It's always fun to listen to Stanley talk about the origins to some of these characters because when Kevin Feige talks about them he talks
About them in the exact same way when they introduce really big comic book characters like this
They try to be as true to the origins of the character as possible
What they were originally intended to be used for but just on a practical level a Silver Surfer
Spin-off movie would obviously spin probably out of a Fantastic Four movie in which is deal with his origins
Norrin Radd where he came from how he came to be
Galactus is Herald when she show all that history you show him then in present day working with the other current Avengers roster
whatever that new roster is going to be I haven't done a whole lot of Avengers 5 videos yet because a lot of the new
Avengers team members will be the new characters that show up during Marvel phase 4
Probably the biggest surprise is kit harington's Black Knight being on a future Avengers team
That's something that I would never guessed Kit Harington 1 being in an Avengers movie
into even bigger surprise the Black Knight being in an Avengers movie if you've never seen it really the only other big
Cinematic appearance of the Silver Surfer was in Fantastic Four 2 when Chris Evans was still playing the character
It's not a good movie. But Laurence Fishburne does the voice for the character Laurence Fishburne now in the MCU is playing Goliath
So hopefully when they bring Silver Surfer in they'll have some sort of Laurence Fishburne Easter egg in the background if they're able to include
That character sometimes that doesn't always happen. He wasn't anywhere to be found during avengers endgame
That was a bit of a surprise, too
but they also didn't include a whole lot of Hank Pym Janet Van Dyne until the very very end if they really are able to
Get their Fantastic Four movie out by 2022. I would say Silver Surfer movie would probably be the year or two after that
Let me know in the comments though
Who is your fan cast for the new Silver Surfer in the MCU?
Could be anybody from their late 20s to early 40s
I imagine it probably would be a whole lot older than that
but if they find a fantastic actor
Like if Keanu Reeves actually wants to be the Silver Surfer Kevin Feige would probably Bend time in space to make that happen
That's how the blade movie wound up getting green lit because Marvel had no intentions of doing a blade movie before
Hershel alley walked in the door since it's still really early days
I'm not expecting to get a whole lot of news about
Fantastic Four or Silver Surfer movies till at least next year sometime
Next year's Comic Con panel is when you'll really start hearing about that stuff
But Kevin Feige did say that they would start teasing all the really big stuff x-men
Fantastic for the next big threat after Thanos which is probably gonna wind up being khalaqtu s' during all the Marvel phase 4 projects
So that's why it's important to watch the TV shows as well as the movies when they drop there will be a Black Widow trailer
Coming late November early December. That's just when Marvel usually drops its spring trailer
They did the same thing for Avengers infinity war in Avengers endgame in the last two years
So when we get new footage or if we hear any big news, I will totally do a video for it
But leave all your requests in the comments below
Congratulations, Ryan Hilton. You're the giveaway winner from my last big Marvel video. Please email me on the about page of my channel
So I can get your details
Everybody click here for my new spider-man far from home post credits scene
venom teaser Marvel phase 4 teaser breakdown in Easter eggs
And click here for my video about Quicksilver coming back during Doctor Strange - thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight